soirée de réveillon jours de fête le
quadra symbole du tambourin
d'estreux ma mère
le roi de nos faibles de fin d'année
mais savons-nous tout ce que nous
consommons car il existe sur le marché
plusieurs versions 2 x dragor de calme
et très nature et puis assaisonnez
cuisse mis sous vide est venu comme ça
la clientèle alors suivi suivi et une
conserve se conservent trois et celui ci
se conserver 25 jours alors cette
terrine une terrine de foie gras mi cuit
c'est une terrine c'est du foie toujours
au départ d'énerver assaisonner me
entérine puis hop et marie toujours très
traditionnel recouvert d'une pellicule
de graisse pour pas clean oxydation nice
ou lui d' avec une pondération sylvie
thilloy ceci est un poids lourd l'a lui
aussi très traditionnel d'énerver saler
poivrer mis en bocaux stérilisés dans la
journée foie gras qui compte
conservation de trois heures alors pas
cessibles pour les consommateurs de s'y
reconnaître
car l'équipe est sage et souvent
incomplets pourtant les associations de
consommateurs demandent depuis fort
longtemps que le pourcentage en foie
gras et la composition soit clairement
indiquée sur tous les produits
accor ou une réglementation dans ce sens